That's enough HTML elements for now
I want to talk about the structure of
an actual HTML document really
quick, before we move on.
Now, what we've been seen before
is just little mark up.
We've been seeing things like this.
You know, little tags, a few little simple tags.
But an actual complete HTML document
has quite a bit more in it
Here is a whole lot more HTML.
Let's take this piece by piece.
But this is what a complete
HTML document look like.
First we have the Doctype, and
this is what kind of HTML this is.
This string right here is,
used to be a lot more complex.
If you were to google for doctypes,
you would see a lot of different answers here.
But now that we are using HTML5,
it has a nice clean simple doctype.
Which is just the string HTML.
Very simple. Okay. Then we have a tag.
This is the, basically the opening
HTML tag, and the closing HTML tag.
This surrounds the entire rest of the document.
That is all it does, it surrounds the entire document.
Now we got this other tag here. The head.
This part of the document has, metadata
and other random stuff. If you were
to include Java script and CSS.
CSS, remember, we talked about, is
the styling sort of stuff.
That would be included in the head section.
Now we also have this little tag here.
The title. And this is the title of the page.
This is what would appear in the top
of your browser window or in your browser tab.
This thing right here. Then we have the body tag.
And the body tag is the actual contents
of the document. And basically, we've been working
just in the body tag in this lesson.
And for most of this course we really just
Going to be focusing on generating
the content that fits between the body tags.
It's - all this other stuff is important.
And you'll see it, and we'll be sending it
over the wire, but it doesn't change very often.
And, you know, it's pretty simple. But it is important
for it to be there. All the interesting stuff
happens between the body tags.
Okay. Let's take another view
of the HTML documents.
They have a structure that
can be visualized like this.
An HTML document, this whole thing,
has a head section, and that is where
we have our title, references to any CSS
files, any Java script files, and that sort of stuff.
And then we have the body section,
and this is where the actual contents
of the document. The stuff you see on the screen.
This is where that comes from.
And this course we're mostly going to focus
on this part of the HTML document.
Just the body section. And there is
a lot of content that can go in there.
We'll discuss briefly CSS and Java script,
and how they fit in on everything,
but for the most part we're going to be
generating the contents. The body
of an HTML document.